[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attends c'est dans on dirait chantal
ladesou dirait la mère de kelly sur la
tête de ma mère c'est que c'est vrai
même volé la roma qui lie ces tout
petits chez la rue c'est la roma kenny
hashtag l'arnaqué 10 mai qui doit
compter mme dubois godet et regarder
mais elle est très belle chantal chante
alors la grande soeur la course il a été
regardé mais c'est un truc d'eau
cela allait plus loin côté il faudrait
faudrait que vous trouviez deux jumeaux
genre igor et grichka bogdanoff
mais si on rigolait c'est vrai et
franchement quand on voit tous les jours
dit elle est très belle deux petites
jumelles sont assez très simple c'est
très simple vous allez regarder on va
bien l'une des jupes et à vous de nous
dire ce que vous avez vu pouvait dire la
vérité aux antilles puis ce sera mon
tour
ils ont regardé et d'annoncer ce que
j'ai vu d'accord bien sûr garder des
places vous devrez dire qu'ils bluffent
alors quelle heure vous y étiez montrez
lui dit la vérité c'est maximum à séméac
sans regarder la brigade et voilà
attention c'est exact alors voit rien
alors qu'est ce qui va ou il est à côté
de vous je vais présenter à deux on
allait les jumelles de l'apéritif rythme
on a envie d'aller picorer
merci ça va bien aller
chantal un truc qui fait son arrivée
dans les deux sens mon boss et
bizarrement il ya eu beaucoup moins de
plaintes sur l'arrivée de chantal
ladesou que sur l'arrivée de nabila déçu
non c'est pas la villa elle est alors
alors il révéla la photo demandé me jean
marc mondoulet jean-marc un parcours dow
jones
jean-marc records d'audience à des
attentats donc là tu as fait une photo
de jean marc morandini ouais ouais voilà
et sur rien d'autre
les chiots l'addition des chutes au nom
il ya d'autres choses peut-être pas des
cloches ohlala moi je vois tu reste
longtemps que je vous assure je ne vais
pas mettre d'accord c'est la répète je
vois un petit écureuil croque une petite
noisette qui dit la vérité la vérité la
vérité c'est que je n'hésite pas à la
caf un record d'audience hier au malawi
à l'inventer alors on sait qu'il peut
pas d'un manque morandini
on va regarder tout de suite qu'il avait
soulagé que maxime mcgraw dans plusieurs
y avait un peu les petites noisettes
total c'est une très belle fabry
vraiment et il paraît que tu es le plein
de plaintes de voilà deux mecs qui tombe
gras gay qui est vrai ont branché c'est
à jamais notre coutlée hanif dans le
contrat à l'as jamais gâcher il
n'apprend rien parce que je suis
amoureuse et michel depuis 40 ans et oui
c'était pas quelquefois mnr je répète m
je serais déjà parti avec toi peut-être
aux eaux
[Applaudissements]
sita et le succès un bravo marie chantal
mois que j'adore c'est mon style
alary c'est mon style c'est bon t'as pas
de faire peur alors là longtemps peiné
cgv ce que tu vois ce que sap en haïti
est ce que tu vois a fêté à petit sapin
un petit sapin à petit sapin avec les
boulangers bull en a pas tant que ça
aura un sentiment d'accord saperaient
les boules
j'ai rêvé de cette séquence depuis sept
ans avec l'épave
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je vois je vous dis je vois une
merguez avec deux boulettes
alors qui dit la vérité totale
vous avez vous avez dit quoi vous petit
à petit ça passe un bac naqib où là bas
c'est sympa lequel lourdes pouvez le
dire à bertrand les les yeux dans les
yeux ce que vous pensez de lui alors toi
dis donc c'est rod est trop beau pour
une drôle d'impression et son mec t'es
marrant coup de main oui d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mon dieu qu'est-ce qui se cache là
dessous
les tâches et les gens voient une énorme
tab
[Applaudissements]
égouttez fin du gag